طبعا اساسا انا بيتي متدمر بتمنى ارجع
لبيتي طبعا ما اتمناش ليش وين اروح وين
اروح انا انا اسمي جمال محمود هاشم يونس
سكان الزهره مدينه الزهره ونحن من
النازحين هنا يا عمي دارنا انهدمت وقاعدين
على المساعدات
حالتنا مبهدله ولا اكل ولا شرب انا عماله
بخبز هنا قسما بالله هذه اخر عشن عندي بعد
كده ما بعرف من وين بدي اجيب الاكل ما
بعرف بدي اجيب طحين من وين انا داري راحت
كل شي فيها انا طلعت من قلب الدار ها شايف
ما فيش شباح البسه عفش ما فيش اكل ما فيش
انا عمري 6 سنه وهي مرتي وهي بنتي وفي
كمان بنت صبيه وفي كمان بنت صبيه اربعه
انفار من وين اجيبلهم ياكلوا انا مش عارف
وين المسؤولين عنا وين المسؤولين عن
الكمبات وين المسؤولين عن النازحين وين
المساعدات بتروح ما في شي يعني احنا بناخذ
من الجمل دانو ابصر شعره حتى ما فيش حاجه
فيش مقاومات الحياه ادوم
انا